hier à toronto il ya eu une réunion
entre trois hommes qui est passée
inaperçue ici pratiquement à montréal
mais qui pourrait avoir un grand effet
sur la deuxième ville en importance au
pays
le ministre ontarien des finances
rencontré le maire de toronto ainsi que
son vis-à-vis fédéral le ministre des
finances du canada pour discuter de
comment stopper la spéculation
immobilière dans la plus grande ville du
pays
il ya eu 33 % d'augmentation des prix
des habitations à toronto depuis un an
la pression des spéculateurs est devenue
intenable le maire prom l'imposition
d'une taxe sur les logements vacants
comme l'a fait vancouver il ya presqu'un
an sur toute la plage du rocher est
économiste principal aux études
économiques au mouvement des caisses
populaires desjardins encourageant les
introductions une surtaxe pour avoir un
impact partie cochet sur montréal et
démons qui opérait depuis depuis
quelques mois et donc ça c'est le
premier élément deuxième élément est que
le marché immobilier
paul cardinal et directeur analystes à
la fédération des chambres immobilières
du québec a pour effectivement avoir un
impact en tout cas on a vu qu'ils
avaient définitivement et un déplacement
à l'étranger en particulier les
asiatiques vers le marché de toronto
toutes les banlieues toute la pointe où
elle finalement le lac ontario où on en
est à des hausses de prix faramineux par
exemple
quel intérêt long à dire des
augmentations prix très très importante
et si l'ontario vient qu'à imiter la
colombie britannique avec une taxe
similaire sur les achats par des
étrangers
on peut par effectif va y aurait
peut-être une perte et aux demandes
d'autres viendraient trotter de montréal
des jours on a plus de dates à
l'étranger dans le marché montréalais de
demain prix marginal mais je reviens
avec des humains sont faites par les
seychelles en 2010 de reus 483 chauffée
par des étrangers non résidents montréal
c'est par neuf en 2008 une augmentation
de 61% et sous-estiment très
probablement la proportion d'acheteurs
étrangers parce que ce qu'on a pu
mesurer les intentions une adresse à
l'extérieur du pays
il y en a qui vont donner une adresse à
les chercheurs d'universités sama fraser
que nous voulons et annick affirme qu'il
ya urgence d'agir pour calmer le marché
immobilier toronto qu'il faut le faire
en tentant de minimiser les impacts
notamment spéculatifs sur les autres
villes notamment celle de morieux
professeur de politique publique josh
gordon propose en fait un nouveau modèle
l'imposition d'une surtaxe sur la valeur
des propriétés de luxe qui seraient
neutralisés par le paiement d'impôts sur
le revenu ça veut dire que cette surtaxe
aura un impact non pas sur les acheteurs
canadiens mais exclusivement sur les
investisseurs étrangers qui ne paient
pas eu de taxes ou d'impôts au canada
non je dirais autant l'après françois
desrosiers professeur à la faculté des
sciences de l'administration de
l'université laval dans la ville de
québec
il n'y a cependant pas de solution
ultime pour contrer la crise de la
spéculation immobilière au canada et
toronto il faut se faire à l'idée que
toronto s'était levé l'international
comme new york et toronto la locomotive
quand même économique et les gens 60 est
pour fait à l'idée qu'ils vivent dans un
sens qui maintenant un centre
international
là les fondamentaux de l'économie sont à
l'oeuvre
que ce soit en termes de création
d'emplois donc le le croissance de
l'économie du salaire la démographie et
l'immigration soutenu et puis également
un problème d'offre puis ça pose le
problème de l'adéquation entre l'offre
et la demande on construit beaucoup
d'appartements
de condos mais les maisons unifamiliales
ça demeure un produit qui très en
demande et où l'or sur le marché ne
satisfait pas la demande donc les prix
continuent de monter un reportage de
radio canada international